[Music]
I’d like to show you an abyss.
Locked within its depths are bewildering and
uncanny abominations.
The keepers of this abyss believe they are
in control…
They are wrong.
This abyss is... the universe of SCP, which
began as a seemingly straightforward website
where community-members create and classify
abominations.
Yet from the site, the franchise has grown
so vast, influenced so many people, that trying
to fathom its totality feels like gazing into
an unending expanse.
So, for this entry into the archive, I’ll
explore not just the universe itself, but
how SCP became one of the most gargantuan
and uncontainable forces on the internet.
And to do that, I have to start at the beginning…
On June 22nd, 2007, an anonymous user made
a post describing, in dry, academic language,
a concrete sculpture that moves when left
unobserved — snapping the necks of anyone
who breaks eye contact with it.
The sparse description was accompanied by
an image labeled ‘SCP-173’ — at the
time, meaningless letters and numbers.
Nobody could have predicted that this was
the birth of something astonishing…
Flash forwards several months, and numerous
people were creating their own anomalies with
the same label format.
Most were rather simple, with SCP-682 for
example, essentially a reptile that’s virtually
invincible.
But the universe was starting to take shape,
with the SCP Foundation determined to be a
secret organization responsible for containing
and studying mysterious phenomena.
And with this framework, things exploded.
On the current website, there are more than
seven thousand unique entries, many of which
are exceedingly original.
The entry for SCP-2521, for example, contains
no text whatsoever, composed instead of strange
infographics that are confusing at first,
until you realize they’re telling you about
a monster that will appear if it’s written
or spoken about.
It’s some genuinely creative horror.
But no two entries are the same.
SCP-106, or The Old Man, is an unfriendly
looking fellow who can corrode any surface
and hunts humans — classic, effective horror.
SCP-294 is a coffee machine that can dispense
anything, including abstract concepts like
musical talent or lethal nuclear waste…
which is definitely a new one.
Certain posts have achieved unique popularity,
like 049, aka The Plague Doctor — who looks
like a human in a 15th century plague outfit…
until you look at an x-ray that reveals the
mask is part of his body.
This entity claims to have a cure to any disease
— which, spoiler alert, is just death.
Not every SCP will connect with every person,
but there are so many entries with such distinct
styles that it’s practically a certainty
that at least one post will draw you in.
And once you’re in, there’s no getting
out, because the posts themselves are just
the tip of the iceberg.
Many of the best entries on the site are text
only, which has inspired a legion of talented
artists to create their own renderings of
what different SCPs might look like.
That original SCP 173, for example, no longer
has an image associated with it — because
the initial photo was actually an unlicensed
picture of the sculpture "Untitled 2004" by
Japanese artist Izumi Kato.
But don’t worry, because there are thousands
of images reinterpreting the evil statue — some
of which are really creative, like this one
from Valdés-Hevia, an artist I’ve covered
before on the channel.
But it’s not just famous SCPs that get this
treatment; there are absolutely stunning works
of art for the most obscure entries — and
I think the reason has to do with the format
of SCPs themselves.
When you read an entry that speaks to you,
it’s hard not to obsess over what the anomaly
might look like, and since many posts have
no art of their own, that obsession often
explodes out into artistic recreations.
But when you read an entry like SCP-610 — or
The Flesh That Hates — about a virus that
turns humans and animals into blobby tendrils
of meat, you don’t just want still images.
You want to see it move.
And you can.
There are literally tens of thousands of animations
and live action short films up on YouTube
that bring SCPs to life in three glorious,
horrifying dimensions.
The channel ForlornFoundry is home to some
of my favorites, creating fancy CGI recreations
of various anomalies.
But complex visuals effects aren’t the only
way to effectively bring an SCP to life.
Some of the most chilling ForlornFoundry adaptations
are the simplest ones — like their unbearably
claustrophobic exploration of SCP-1562: an
infinite tunnel slide that is impossible to
escape from once you get stuck within its
chasmal depths.
Or the similar SCP-087, a pitch-black staircase
you can never reach the bottom of.
My favorite moment in this video is when someone
trapped on the stairs drops a coin off the
railing, and the anticipated sound of the
coin hitting the ground just… never comes.
It’s seriously clever filmmaking, conveying
the dread and anxiety of the original entry.
And I think that’s part of what motivates
ForlornFoundry and similar channels — a
desire to recreate how the best SCPs feel
when you read them.
And I’m guessing that’s why there are
so many adaptations of SCP-3008…
“IKEA.
A place where children could play while their
parents shop.
Where friends could share good cheer.
This vision has come to pass.
IKEA has just opened its 70th store-” The
most renowned SCP in this sub-category of
immeasurable spaces is the infinite IKEA — an
extradimensional version of the already labyrinthine
retail store that literally never ends.
Something about wandering the furniture displays
in perpetuity, forever unable to find your
way back to the entrance, has struck a chord
with the internet — leading to countless
digital recreations.
I’ve seen references to the infinite IKEA
well beyond the sphere of SCP.
There are entire fan games about this concept,
letting you get lost among the endless furniture
displays as a gnawing loneliness sets in.
It’s a sensation that I find… strangely
familiar.
I’m sure many of us have early memories
of getting separated from our parents in the
supermarket.
Even if it was just for a brief moment, the
aisles suddenly felt larger and more threatening,
and there was a sense that you’d never find
a way out.
I think many of the most well-known SCPs are
rooted in these half-remembered childhood
fears, which helps explain their infectious
popularity.
There’s something universal about the vertigo
of a really big staircase or, again, an empty
store that allows SCPs to leave a wide audience
feeling unsettled.
…But they’re also kind of hilarious.
Like, being stuck forever in an IKEA is disturbing,
yet at the same time, really funny in a way
that’s difficult to quantify.
When night falls in the store, faceless monsters
wearing IKEA employee uniforms start hunting
you through the dark — and while logically
that should make things scarier, to me it
only adds to the humor.
This paradoxical undercurrent of comedy is
present in a lot of SCPs.
SCP-1609 was a chair that helpfully teleported
to people when they needed to sit down, until
someone put it through a woodchipper, turning
it into a rageful pile of mulch that teleports
into peoples’ lungs.
And while murderous sawdust would be terrifying…
it’s pretty hysterical in the abstract.
And this, I believe, is the other massive
component to SCP’s unparalleled expansion.
Even if every entry won’t scare you, chances
are at least a few will make you laugh.
And the more of these stories you read, the
funnier it all seems to get…
The question of why a never-ending ensemble
of terrors is so amusing can best be answered
by the genre-bending horror-comedy film The
Cabin in the Woods.
Probably the closest thing to a big-budget
SCP movie, the story involves five friends
vacationing at a remote cabin unprepared for
the terrors that await them.
What at first feels like every horror movie
ever quickly goes off the rails, as we learn
the whole thing is being orchestrated by a
secret organization that keeps every conceivable
type of monster contained in an underground
facility — monsters they then unleash on
unsuspecting youths to appease the old gods.
This overabundance of horrors is the key to
the film’s humor.
A single monster stalking a group of innocents
is horrifying, but a thousand monsters of
contrasting origins and genres starts to become,
well, comical.
And it’s this principle that makes the SCP
series so entertaining.
Yet beyond the absurdity of both The Cabin
in the Woods and SCP is a stark commentary
on desensitization.
In the film, the technicians in charge of
the facility are completely numb to the reality
of what they’re doing, taking bets on which
monsters will slaughter the cabin-goers.
In many SCP stories, Foundation employees
behave the same way, having become apathetic
to human suffering after a lifetime of containing
anomalies.
And both narratives implicate the viewer as
well.
In Cabin in the Woods, the Old Gods are a
clear stand in for the audience —unfeeling
spectators who demand sacrifice.
Likewise, with SCP, the more entries you read,
the more you inhabit the perspective of a
Foundation employee clocking in to their job,
increasingly unafraid of the nightmares within...
The ability of SCP to immerse you, to make
you feel like you’re a part of the universe
— has made its stranglehold on the internet
inescapable.
It leaves you with a desire to go deeper,
to experience the narratives firsthand — and
I’d wager that’s why games based on the
franchise are so insanely prevalent.
SCP: Containment Breach is quite possibly
the most well-known thing to ever crawl out
of the franchise.
The indie game has an easy to understand haunted
house format, where the deadliest anomalies
escape and hunt you through a dimly lit facility.
And shortly after its release, Containment
Breach exploded on YouTube, with the view
counts on playthroughs so high, I’d wager
it’s how many were introduced to SCP in
the first place.
But like the wiki itself, SCP games have come
a long way since Containment Breach — with
the most impressive from a standpoint of sheer
creativity probably being Secret Files.
Released in 2022, this title puts you in the
shoes of a newcomer to the Foundation who
learns about past SCPs while working in the
archives.
The story is divided into chapters, each a
gameplay and art-style so distinct, they might
as well be different games.
For example, one chapter is dedicated to the
famous SCP-701, or The Hanged King's Tragedy
— a 17th century play that causes anyone
who performs it to lose their mind.
Appropriately, the chapter itself is chaotic
and psychedelic, with the player never certain
what’s real and what’s a product of the
anomaly affecting their mind.
From an artistic perspective, it’s one of
the more immersive ways to experience a reality-bending
SCP, and can at times be genuinely spooky.
On the opposite end of the tonal spectrum
is the chapter on SCP-1762 — a cardboard
box that acts as a portal to a Narnia-esque
magical land that paper dragons come out of.
The original entry is famous for its uniquely
non-horror approach, and to reflect this the
art style of this chapter is bright and painterly.
And the gameplay is equally charming — instead
of running for your life, you use stickers
to bandage the wings of paper dragons and
practice your penny flute for the big recital.
The whole chapter, I kept waiting for things
to get dark, and while like the original entry
there is some truly tear-jerking stuff as
the magical land starts to fade away — for
the most part, the chapter retains its storybook
presentation throughout.
Taken as a whole, Secret Files is the ultimate
proof of SCP’s versatility — that it can
be used to tell stories in any genre.
The infinite variability of SCP means that
no single game could ever embody the series
in its totality — which hasn’t stopped
fans from trying.
SCP: Fragmented Minds is an upcoming crowdsourced
game that seems massively ambitious, taking
a more combat-oriented approach in contrast
to the more passive Secret Files.
Fragmented Minds seems to have a lot of passion
behind it, but more than that, it seems symptomatic
of a larger dream.
There’s a phantom of a big-budget, triple-A
SCP game that haunts the ever-growing fanbase,
the feverish hope that one day, a mainline
studio might take a swing at this franchise.
It doesn’t seem impossible — in fact,
it might have already happened.
The majority of the game Control revolves
around the secretive Federal Bureau of Control,
an off-the-books government agency created
to seek out, contain, and categorize supernatural
items called Objects of Power.
And if that sounds familiar, it should, because
Control and SCP are explicitly, irrevocably,
intertwined.
The makers of Control have stated that the
game’s story and atmosphere are heavily
influenced by the SCP series.
Think about that for a second: a major, award-winning
company made what is, on some level, a fan
game of an indie-internet horror anthology
— that’s pretty unheard of.
But the connection between the franchises
goes deeper.
Control takes place within an altered building
called The Oldest House — an ever-changing
structure where the Bureau has set up headquarters.
Nothing about The Oldest House makes scientific
sense — its interior is infinitely larger
than its exterior, certain rooms are thresholds
to other dimensions, and the building itself
can only be seen by someone explicitly looking
for it.
And yet despite this, every description of
The Oldest House and the altered objects housed
within are written in the same dry, confident
tone — deeply reminiscent of the language
used in SCP entries.
The same confidence extends to in-game recordings
you can find, where researchers will discuss
mind-shattering phenomena like it’s all
business as usual.
There’s even an insane puppet show called
Threshold Kids the Bureau created to reassure
children that there’s definitely nothing
to worry about.
Sure, the building seems malignant and is
full of floating zombies, but everything is
under control.
It only takes a few minutes of actual gameplay
to make it clear that no one in the game Control
is actually, well, in control.
The notion that layers of bureaucracy and
paperwork can actually contain the unfathomable
horrors long term is just an illusion.
And the same is true at the SCP Foundation.
Despite the Foundation’s best efforts, the
deeper into the lore you get, the more patterns
of administrative dysfunction emerge.
As in Control, The Foundation is ultimately
an underequipped group fighting a losing battle
against forces they can’t truly understand.
Many of the most complex recent stories set
in the SCP universe emphasize this hopelessness
— this sense that the Foundation isn’t
as in control as they’d like to believe.
The recent 20-minute film 096 by Klay Abele
explores the tragedy and horror that occur
when the cracks in the Foundation’s system
start to show.
The film’s title comes from SCP-096 — a
monster that hunts down anyone who looks at
its face — whether it be directly, via video
recording, or even a photograph.
Yet the other monster haunting the film is
the Foundation itself — a faceless bureaucracy
laden with internal corruption that can be
dangerous as the anomalies it contains.
The fact that this franchise went from a bunch
of people sharing spooky ideas on a message
board to something this thematically dense
is pretty astonishing.
And 096 isn’t the only SCP adaptation of
its level of quality on YouTube.
SCP: Overlord by Steven Handcock and Evan
Muir is an even lengthier short film that
captures a similar atmosphere of powerlessness.
A tightly-wound thriller, it follows a group
of Foundation military operatives who are
slowly picked off by an incomprehensible threat
— made all the more unsettling by the fact
that the film never tells you which SCP is
taking them out.
These filmmakers have made other shorts set
in this universe that also don’t fully explain
which anomaly the protagonists are dealing
with — which helps put the viewer in their
shoes and makes everything tenser.
There’s a clear hunger for cinematic takes
on this franchise — SCP: Overlord, for example,
has almost eighteen million views.
As was the case with the games, I’m sure
a lot of fans discovered SCP through these
videos.
And some of these new fans will inevitably
create their own SCPs, which will in turn
produce more fan content which will reach
new people, continuing an infinite, self-perpetuating
cycle — The idea of a website dedicated
to uncanny terrors that slowly takes over
the internet is exactly the sort of thing
one might expect to find on the SCP wiki — but
in the ultimate twist, that description applies
to the wiki itself.
The SCP series and its popularity is the kind
of anomalous phenomena the Foundation would
want to contain.
But it can’t be contained.
There are graphic novels, short stories, other
organizations, alternate universes — the
fandom seems to be ever-expanding, completely
out of anyone’s control…
And perhaps that’s as it should be.
While massive and unwieldy, there is such
a range of styles and genres across this franchise
that I truly believe it has something for
everyone.
In the end, the most important thing the SCP
Foundation offers is a canvas, upon which
ordinary, passionate creators can leave their
mark.
I think that’s the real secret to its success
and why this abyss — unfathomable though
it may be — is worth staring into.
As always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.